I'm going to try and convince you of how
very critically important order is to
something like a secrets not just
because I say is but because if you'd
vote it could be in some serious trouble
so watch with me this is a well this is
a series right so it's a sequence one
making a half a third they a quarter a
bit negative 1/6 and I'm just summing
good so I've turned it into a series
okay now it turns out that the order of
this thing is everything if everything
now to try to illustrate that for you um
what is this equal to
okay now let's just pretend I don't know
what it's equal to because as a matter
of fact I do you know what it's equal to
which is mind-blowing enough but I'll
tell you that at the end of this okay
suppose I don't know what it's equal to
okay it is equal to something by the way
it can be rigorously proven that this
this series does have an actual value
okay by the way on this series is
important hazard it's important enough
to have a name it's called the
alternating can you see why it's called
off me plus minus plus minus plus minus
the alternating harmonic series harmonic
as in like musical notes because if you
divide up that how do we get the Western
scale is by dividing up a string held
attention into certain ratios okay so
that's the yes okay now okay I'm going
to treated it I'm gonna do some very
very ordinary things with it okay for
those of you who are in my class
slaughter you even more ordinary than
those okay watch he's the first thing
I'm gonna do I'm gonna multiply this
thing by two now I find multiplying they
let the attack rights to do that
corresponds to multiplying everything on
the right hand side every single term in
the series by to do you agree with that
it's just doubling its okay so I'm just
going to I'm not even going to simplify
I'm just going to write it out all
doubled okay so I'm gonna get 2 minus 2
over 2 plus 2/3 minus 2 over 4 that's 2
feet - and so on okay now whenever I
look at this guy right
I haven't done anything unusual anything
out of the ordinary now I'm just going
to simplify
it's just fractions and I can write them
in simple forms okay so for instance oh
no I'm not gonna do any adding or
subtracting no adequate subtracting
involved which is usually where a trick
can be probably okay
I'm looking to anything like that I'm
just going to simplify the fraction so
I've got 2 minus 1 wait you mean to exer
oh yeah sorry
I haven't yeah I don't divide it I'm
just simplifying practical to minus 1
plus that's already the simplest thing
you get what's this guy that's as simple
as it gets
- and it's someone you care with that
okay now once I've done this you can see
I have a series of pins they have the
same denominator do you agree that like
for example I mean these are both whole
numbers so I can put them together these
are both over 3 you if I kept going I'd
have to deliver 5 and no no no no ok so
let me just collect like terms eyes on
the road okay what's this guy this is
one okay for reasons that I hope become
really obvious in a second I'm going to
skip this two-thirds I'm going to write
them minus 1 over 2 first because it
doesn't match up with anything
then I've got 2/3 minus 1/3 what's 2/3
minus of that it's 1/3 now I can write
more terms if you like I could write
more if you want but I can tell you
right now that this is what you get
now although the second home in a second
I multiplied by 2 and what I got when I
multiplied by 2 was really where I
started
sorry everyone I've heard the universe
okay now here's the really interesting
thing okay there's a few things to point
out let me just um as an aside let me
talk to all the people who died talk
lossy and who see me you know infinite
series a really dicey thing you have to
be careful with them right now last year
I put some sheets with that kind of
thing but let me tell you right now one
of the reasons why I could play those
tricks is that what I had over here was
what we call the divergent series so
it's valued like say the series 1 plus 2
Plus 3 plus 4 it just sort of blows up
it never goes toward anything this this
series the alternating harmonic series
it actually goes it goes to a
well-defined value and its value is even
more mind-blowing it's log 2 ok now the
strange thing though is that even though
all mathematicians agree that this whole
series if you take it to infinity is log
2 if all you do let's just think about
this I multiplied by 2 any problems
there I can multiply budgets anything I
simplified some fractions do you agree
that 2 over 2 is 1 and 2 and 4 is off no
big deal took mathematicians a long time
to realize the big deal was here what
could you from this line to this line
actually do I just look past it yeah
the number of terms collapse the reason
why I could collapse them is because I
sort of mentioned it but I sort of
glossed over it as well see how I moved
this term I moved it up one right and
that meant these two guys simplified
together and it's what with it you know
subsequent o Simhadri as well okay that
mere act of shifting things around a
little bit
rearranging actually changes what the
Sun is there's a there's a property
property a theorem to do this it's
called the Riemann series theorem or
than a riemann rearrangement here which
says there are certain kinds of series
like this where if you muck with the
ward are all you have to do is rearrange
these little and you'll come out with
something completely different